ternant la connaissance de la maladie qu
vide nous sommes aussi très attentifs
aux remontées du terrain ont remonté des
professionnels de santé qui sont
quotidiennes ainsi le conseil national
professionnel des orl les oto rhino
laryngologiste nous a signalé la
recrudescence de cas danos me brutale
qui correspond en fait à la disparition
brutale de l'odorat on n'a plus la
capacité de détecter les odeurs sans
obstruction du nez sans obstruction
nasale sans écoulement et qui peut donc
survenir de façon isolée
il convient devant la constatation de ce
signe qui est assez rare de prendre la
tâche de son médecin traitant
c'est-à-dire de l'appeler puisque je
vous rappelle qu'il ne faut pas se
rendre au cabinet et dans ce cas
d'éviter là encore davantage tout
automédication toute prise de
corticoïdes ou d'anti inflammatoires non
stéroïdiens sans avis spécialisés de son
médecin ou de son url vous le savez la
recherche française avance aussi sur la
thérapeutique sur les médicaments sur
des essais de traitement
les antirétroviraux des antiviraux de
nouveaux nombreuses molécules associées
une étude dont on a beaucoup parlé aussi
sur l'idh roxy chloroquine toutes ces
pistes sont intéressantes parce qu'elles
vont fournir des données scientifiques
afin de statuer sur l'efficacité et
l'innocuité des molécules
nous soutenons fortement la recherche
clinique et faisons en sorte que le tout
les ces protocoles soient étudiées dans
les meilleures conditions pour une
réponse rapide et une mise en place dans
les plus brefs délais